I think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much you know
they have to say really what's the worst
that could go wrong you know kind of
soft to death you know you're not gonna
die of exposure people talk about you
know life family balance I had done any
decision can be divided into what do I
need to do versus how and when do I need
to do it wanna be happy build our life
not just the business hey seven
Carmichael and this channel is created
to help you overcome the number one
challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you as well
you've got Michael Jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the top ten
traits that rich people have in common
okay let's tick it off with trait number
one be driven with Mark Cuban people
talk about you know life family balance
I had none I mean I literally remember
dating some girl this is truth and it
was like we'd been dating a couple years
and like it mark you're so into your
work I mean I want to pick a fence I
want a house I want kids you know I mean
you it's me or your job and I was like
or mean you're me or your company and I
was like what's your name again
[Music]
I'm like if you don't know me well
enough by now two years know that I'm
trivial I mean there was no balanced
trait number to act on your ideas with
Jeff Bezos I came across the fact so
this is 1994 nobody has heard of the
internet very very few people and I came
across the fact that the web world wide
web was growing at something like
twenty-three hundred percent a year this
is an i-94 and anything growing that
fast is even if it's baseline usage
today is tiny it's growing so fast it's
gonna be big and so I looked at that and
I was like there's got to be I should
come up with a business idea then they
get you know on the Internet and then
let the internet go around this and we
can keep working on it and so I made a
list of products that I might saw online
and I started force ranking them and I
picked books because books is super
unusual in one respect which is that
they're more book items in the book
category than there are items in the
other category the three million
different books active and in print
around the world in a given time so my
my the founding idea of Amazon was to
build Universal selection of books the
biggest bookstores only had one hundred
and fifty thousand titles and so that's
what I did and I you know I hired a
small team and we built we built the
software I moved to Seattle and when you
told your parents you're gonna equip de
sha where you're successful making
presumably a fair amount of money yeah
and you told your wife McKenzie that
you're gonna move across the country
what did they all say they were
immediately and reflexively supportive
right after they asked the question
what's the internet treat number three
make energizing decisions with Mel
Robbins any decision can be divided into
what do I need to do versus how and when
do I need to do it for the what that is
intuition and by intuition I use the
word energy and the way to answer any
question for yourself personally that
you don't immediately know the answer to
is to ask this question does it energize
and expand my life
or does it drink it if it energizes and
expands your life the answer is hell yes
you should absolutely do it that is what
you should do if the decision shrinks
you or it deflates you then the answer's
hell no you should not do it this is an
incredible tool to use in deal-making by
the way because you know I'm in the
middle of negotiating a massive media
deal at the moment and it's something
I've always wanted to do and when you're
negotiating for something you really
want whether it's somebody that you're
dating or you know it's a salary or
whatever it in my case it's a massive
media deal you can get really ego driven
right right you can start to get very
attached to the deal or to the person
with or whatever but you have to stop
and ask yourself is this deal or this
person actually expanding but and
energizing are or are there aspects of
it that deplete and shrink me and if
there's any aspect of it that depletes
and shrinks you either have to change
that aspect of the deal or the
relationship structure where you have to
say no period right if you decide that
yet it energizes me and I really want to
do it then that's what you want next
you've got to think about the outcome
which is how and when you make it happen
trait number four don't fear fear too
much with Elon Musk
what motivations that people need to
harness to try to make change as opposed
to just reading about change that's not
supposed to be an easy question either
oh it's it's this well like I said I
think if you if you study engineering
and you figure out how to design new
things then it's relatively easy to
start a company you just need to get a
few like-minded people with you and and
then focus on creating a prototype for
compelling prototypes as soon as
possible and then
that you know there's a strong venture
capital industry in this country that
will give you funding to take things to
the next level and that that's all there
is to it
and you might if you know tried a few
times might may or may not succeed but I
think sometimes people fear fear
starting a company too much you know to
say really what's the worst that could
go wrong you know kind of stuff to death
you know you're not gonna die of
exposure what's worse they can go wrong
also if you want to have more confidence
check in my 254 series they're free the
link to join are in the description
below some people see the thing that
they want and some people see the thing
that prevents them from getting the
thing that they want you might want to
get honest with yourself like instead of
doing this be a millionaire or do this
do you really because you can make it
happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
you really have to believe the
Internet's going to be mainstream a lot
of people are gonna get out there and
use it trick number five take risks with
Mark Zuckerberg in a world that's
changing so quickly the biggest risk you
can take is not taking any risk and I
really think that that's true right a
lot of people I think think that you
know whenever it comes to whatever you
get yourself into a position where you
have to make some some big shift and
direction or do something you know
they're always people are going to point
to the downside risks of that decision
and locally there may be right right I
mean if for any given decision that
you're gonna make there's upside and
downside but in aggregate if you are
stagnant and you don't make those
changes then then I think you're
guaranteed to fail right and not not
catch up so to some degree I think it's
really right that over time the biggest
risk that you can take is to not take
any risks trait number six be a learner
with Bill Gates it's an incredible time
to be a learner I remember when I was
young and I had the world but with just
one of Warren's products and it was very
good but yeah I always felt like I want
to get into this more depth I want to
kind of better today the videos that are
online
the courses that you can buy with the
very best professors it's phenomenal
you know take a subject like weather or
climate change yeah or what's going on
in economics what's known what's not
known
now with the foundation a lot of what I
need to learn it's about biology making
vaccines and what's going on with these
these various diseases this is a
phenomenal time to be a curious person
the information that's out there you
know I have a my my biggest problem is
that I stay up too late cuz I'm reading
and then I'm a little bit tired the next
day trait number seven be willing to ask
for help with simon Sinek the biggest
lesson I learned was thank goodness I
learned it pretty early on which is and
I think a lot of business owners make
this mistake which is because I was the
boss you know in my own mind yeah I
thought I had to know all the answers
and if I didn't I thought I had to
pretend that I did and that's stupid and
what I learned is that just because I
may have the the top position in the
hierarchy I I'm not expected to know
everything and if I pretend to know
everything it diminishes the value of
all the great ideas and the great
intelligence around me and when things
got difficult I would never admit it
right I would just put on a brave face
and show up every day and and the the
the biggest lesson I learned was to say
I don't know I don't understand or I
need help at any level about any subject
yeah and amazingly I was always
surrounded by people who wanted to help
or who knew answers but they never
offered to help or offer the answers
because they didn't think I needed it
because I kept pretending that I knew it
all right not to mention the fact that
nobody likes a know-it-all so that was
huge for me and and when I was willing
to ask for help and an accept it when it
was offered and and sort of accept the
humility of the fact that other people
know a lot more about a lot of things
than I know I know one thing you know
and they know lots of things
that's when things really started to
move because we were now a team like we
were actually working together trait
number eight become
the-best-version-of-yourself with Oprah
Winfrey I have paid attention to my life
because I understand that my life just
like your life is always speaking to you
where you are in the language with the
people with the circumstances and
experiences that you can understand and
interpret if you are willing to see that
always life God is speaking to you now
it took me a while to actually really
get this and to understand it but once I
did I started paying attention to
everything and one of the reasons why I
can now accept the fact that I can offer
my gatherings of information and wisdom
and call myself a spiritual teacher is
that every single person who ever came
on my show and I hear there was like
37,000 guests I've talked to a lot of
them came from dysfunction and a lot of
them wouldn't appear to be teachers but
every one of them had something to say
that was meaningful and valuable and
that I could use to grow myself into the
best of myself which is what all of our
jobs are your number one job is to
become more of yourself and to grow
yourself into the best of yourself trait
number nine listen to your gut with
Kevin O'Leary
I listen to my gut it's not scientific
I've learned over time and I think every
entrepreneur should trust their feelings
because I've learned every time I don't
listen to my gut I lose money every time
I say to myself no never wrong with that
I second-guess myself I lose money
you have to listen successful
entrepreneurs have a spider-sense I
really believe that they know what's
right they know what's wrong they have
to listen to themselves and it doesn't
always work out but the minute you
second-guess yourself you're screwed you
really are
you you are no longer a leader people
that follow you into dark places have to
trust you and you have to trust yourself
and treat number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip is believe in
your ideas with Sara Blakely I had never
taken a business class I'd never worked
in fashion or retail and I had $5,000 in
savings I just moved out of my mother's
house I was 27 years old and I was
probably dating a loser at the time so
there you have it there I was and I you
know wanted to wear these pants I didn't
know where to go so I decided I've got
to get this made I went on the internet
and I started looking up hosiery mills
and I went to a web site called Thomas
registry com which lists all
manufacturers in the United States now
it's called Thomas net but they listed
it for me and lucky for me most of the
hosiery manufacturers are in North
Carolina while I was in Atlanta Georgia
at the time so I started picking up the
phone and calling all these
manufacturers and introducing myself
over the phone and I I just I couldn't
get the right person on the phone people
kept transferring me around I mean I
imagine on the other end of the line
them saying you know here there's a girl
online so she's gonna transform her own
but like which department am I supposed
to send her to everyone kept either
hanging up on me saying no thanks it's
not a good idea so I believed in my own
idea enough though that I realized okay
I want to patent this I may be having
some difficulty right now getting
someone to help me make the idea but I
want to protect it so I went and looked
up on the internet martindale-hubbell
which is a website that lists attorneys
and they will tell you the ranking and
you know sort of the rating next to them
I started looking for a female patent
attorney in the state of Georgia and I
couldn't find one so I called the
Georgia Chamber of Commerce and I
introduced myself said I'm looking for a
female patent attorney and they told me
that there actually was not a female
patent attorney in the state of Georgia
at the time so I said okay I got it I'm
gonna go describe this to a man
and we'll see what happens and I went on
the website I picked three different law
firms I cold call to each law firm I put
on my nicest suit from selling fax
machines that I had I had my lucky red
backpack that was with me the entire
journey of Spanx and I went and met with
them well they all quoted me between
three and five thousand dollars to
patent it and I had five thousand
dollars set aside in my savings to do
this so I decided to patent it myself
well the attorney that ended up helping
me at the very end of this process he
admitted to me that when I came to him
with the idea that he thought my idea
was so bad when I met with him that he
actually thought I had been sent by
candid camera which completely makes
perfect sense because I was as I was
sitting in the room explaining it to him
he kept looking around the room and he
later said to me he said Sarah I really
have to tell you I either thought you
were sent by candid camera or that I was
being pranked by some of my guy friends
because you know you whipped out the
pantyhose you're showing me the the
crotch and where you cut these and how
you're gonna change the world and it's
like I wasn't used to that now I have a
special bonus clip with EDM I let on how
to be more decisive that I think you're
gonna enjoy but before that it's time
for the three-point landing questions
let's go from just watching a video to
taking action here we go question number
one what is the Michael Jordan level
idea that you need to believe more in
number two who are three people that you
can ask for help with this week and
number three what's one energizing
decision that you need to make today and
if you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos we do something after it give me
a hashtag believe down in the comments
and make that commitment to yourself
count you've got to start to build a
habit of being decisive successful
people happy people leaders are decisive
people and I believe somewhere if
there's a hundred problems challenges in
life 85 of them should be decided
immediately with not a lot of
deliberation
then certainty and massive action will
eliminate that challenge in that problem
most of the time it's the people who
procrastinate on the problem or ignore
it or think it might go away that gives
that problem time to magnify to fester
to grow to where now it's become bigger
than it needed to be
if you want to know why poverty is not
an accident check out the video right
there next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there people cringe also always say it's
not about passion
everybody's got passion for something
yeah right don't follow your passions
follow your efforts